نشاهد
[موسيقى]
مباشره من نتابعه الان مباشره
الياس الياس
كرا لحظه لحظه لقد
جءنا ربما
يطلب من فريق الجزيره اذا اعلن اعلن عن
هذه المنطقه
عمروش زومت
كم اذا يعلنون عن هذه المنطقه منطقه
عسكريه مغلقه ويحاولون ابعادنا الان من
هذا المكان سنرى طبعا هم يقولون بان هنالك
قرارا من قائد
المنطقه الجنوبيه لاعلان هذه المنطقه
منطقه عسكريه
مغلقه
اذا سنحاول ان نتحق يعني يحاولون ابعادنا
من اكثر من مكان في منطقه غلاف
غزه اصبح طبعا هذا مشهدا
يتكرر نعم نتابعك
الياس ونش
الى انكم تتعرضون الان لذه المضايقات
والمطالبات باخلاء هذا الموقع كما تقول
الذي يحولونه الى منطقه عسكريه
مغلقه ويطلبون من الاطقم
الصحفيه ومنها طاقم الجزيره
بمغادرتها هذه المنطقه داخل غلاف غزه كما
نتابع مع
الياس نعم بالفعل ولم يعد طبعا مكان نحاول
ان نصل
وسروا الشهريه وح ابعادنا عن المكان الان
هم يطلبون منا
نغادر ربما سيكون امامنا دقائق فقط معدوده
لمغادره هذا المكان
سلمى طبعا تزم مع استمرار الاشتباكات ايضا
على السياج الح
[موسيقى]
الجزير
نعم no
need ريوت ربما سيحاول فريق الجزيره
سيحاول
الياس
الانتقال الى موقع
اخر لكن كما تابعنا مع الياس كل
المغادره بالتالي هي مضايقات لفريق
الجزيره كما نتابع حتى يعرقل متابعته لهذه
التطورات المرتبطه بمحاولات تسلل وباشتراك
مستمره على الحدود ووصول بعض عناصر
المقاومه الى مناطق قريبه جدا او داخل
الغلاف مثل ما تابعنا قبل
قليل يحملون اذا عدتهم الياس كرام والمصور
وفريق الجزيره الموجود في هذا الموقع
للتغطيه الاخباريه لكنهم يمنعون من اداء
عملهم كما نشاهد هي مضايقات يتعرض لها
فريق الجزيره ذكر الياس كرام وتابعنا خلال
الايام
الماضيه انه يطلب منهم مرارا وتكرارا لدى
وصولهم الى اي موقع داخل غلاف غزه للقيام
بعملهم يطلب منهم المغادره في كل مره بذيع
اعلان هذه المواقع مناطق عسكريه مغلقه
طيب
كز خليها
ز
فوريو هذه المحاولات كلها تتكرر
نعم في كل مكان نذهب اليه طبعا محاوله
لتعتيم الصوره لاغلاق
البر
طبعا الياس ان كنت تسمعني نسال فقط
بالاضافه الى منعكم من العمل في هذه
المواقع في كل مره مرارا وتكرارا كما
نشاهد ويحاولون اخلاك من اي موقع تقومون
فيه بعملكم ما نوع ربما الممارسات الاخرى
التي تتعرضون لها من قبل جنود الاحتلال
للحيلوله دون ادائك لعمكم
هناك يعني الاعمال التي رايتها الان حقيقه
مريم في محاوله ابعادنا دائما واغلاق
الصوره لكن هنالك ايضا بعض الاطقم الصحفيه
في مدن اسرائيليه تعرضت ايضا للاعتداء حتى
من من الشرطه الاسرائيليه نفسها لاسباب
واهيه يعني لا يمكن
تفسيرها الرائعه التي يقدمونها
الياس انقطعت الصوره من غلاف غزه مع الياس
كرام
بفعل القوه كما كنا نتابع اجبروا على
اغلاق البث من غلاف غزه اجبر فريق الجزيره
على وقف عمله في هذا الموقع و يلاحقهم
جنود الاحتلال كما تابعنا مع الياس كرام
لمنعهم من اداء عملهم ولتعطي الصوره ايضا
لكن بالتاكيد سنتابع مع الياس كرام من
موقع اخر سينتقل اليه لايفاد بكل التفاصيل
والمتابعات والجزيره تتابع دائما اي جديد
تحت اي ظروف